IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY, AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
PRESIDENT TRUMP APPEARS THIS
AFTERNOON AT A EVENT IN
WEST VIRGINIA AFTER ORDERING THE
NATIONAL GUARD TO THE MEXICAN
BORDER TO COMBAT ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION AND DRUG SMUGGLING.
HE REMAINS FIRM ON HIS PLANS TO
SECURE THE BORDER WITH OUR
MILITARY AS THE SITUATION, HE
SAYS, HAS REACHED A POINT OF
CRISIS.
>> WE HAVE TO HAVE STRONG
BORDERS.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE THE WALL.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE OUR WALL AND
WE ARE GOING TO GET IT VERY
STRONGLY.
THE MILITARY IS GOING TO BE
BUILDING SOME OF THAT.
WE CANNOT LET PEOPLE ENTER OUR
COUNTRY.
WE HAVE NO IDEA WHO THEY ARE,
WHAT THEY DO, WHERE THEY CAME
FROM.
WE HAVE NO IDEA WHAT THEIR
RECORDS ARE.
WE ARE WORKING OUT SYSTEMS NOW,
AND WE CALLED OUT THE
NATIONAL GUARD.
WE ARE DOING A REAL JOB.
I WILL TELL YOU WHAT, THE LAWS
OF THIS COUNTRY HAVE TO BE
STRENGTHENED AND TOUGHENED.
>> Kimberly: THE PENTAGON
HASN'T DETERMINED WHETHER TROOPS
WILL BE ARMED.
THE MOVE DRAWING HEAVY CRITICISM
FROM THE LEFT WHO CLAIM THIS IS
A RALLYING CRY TO THE PRESIDENTS
BASE.
>> THIS PRESIDENT DOESN'T PLAN
OUT ANYTHING, DOESN'T
COORDINATED.
HE IS USING OUR TROOPS AS A
POLITICAL PLOY SO WE CAN BOAST
HIS NUMBERS WITH HIS VOTERS.
>> I DON'T SEE THE URGENCY BUT
THERE CLEARLY IS A POLITICAL
IMPERATIVE.
POLITICAL URGENCY MIGHT BE
DIFFERENT THAN NATIONAL SECURITY
URGENCY.
>> SHAM MIGHT BE THE WORD YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR.
>> BORDER SECURITY IS AN ISSUE
THAT WON HIM LOTS OF SUPPORT
DURING THE CAMPAIGN, AND HE
EXPLAINED TO THAT BASE AGAIN.
>> THIS IS MORE ABOUT THE
POLITICS, GIVEN THE HOW.
THE WHEELS HAVE KIND OF COME OFF
FOR THE PRESIDENT ON THE DACA
SIDE OF THINGS WHEN YOU GET ANN
COULTER AND MANY ON THE
CONSERVATIVE, HARD RIGHT SAYING
WHAT THE HELL IS YOUR PROBLEM?
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
THAT RATTLED HIM.
>> Kimberly: GREG, ISN'T A
RALLYING CALL TO THE BASE?
ANN COULTER.
>> Greg: SHE RUNS THE WHOLE
WORLD.
THERE ARE TWO ANGLES THEY ARE
WORKING.
THE LEFT IS CALLING IT SECURITY
THEATER.
SECURITY THEATER.
IT IS LEFT-WING ACTIVIST THEATER
BECAUSE THE ILLEGAL BORDER
CROSSING WAS MANUFACTURED BY AN
ACTIVIST GROUP.
THE CARAVAN WAS ORGANIZED TO
CREATE A CONFRONTATION.
BUT TRUMP WAS ABLE TO STOP THE
CONFRONTATION BY CREATING A
METAPHORICAL WALL, I.E.,
HIMSELF, SAYING I AM SENDING IN
THE ARMY.
THE WHOLE THING CAPITULATED IN
MEXICO COOPERATING.
HE WON THIS ROUND IN A HIGHLY
VISUAL MANNER.
THE NEW MEDIA ANGLE IS THIS
WASN'T A STORY UNTIL TRUMP
NEEDED ONE.
NOBODY EVER KNEW ABOUT THIS
CARAVAN.
WELL, YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
YOU FIGURED OUT HOW TRUMP
WORKED.
HE TAKES A STORY THAT THE MEDIA
IGNORES AND THEN HE MAKES IT HIS
STORY.
HE TAKES SOMETHING THAT IS VERY
VISUAL THAT PEOPLE UNDERSTAND,
AND HE MAKES IT A NATIONAL STORY
AND HE MAKES IT A NATIONAL STOR
STORY.
MUCH LIKE WHAT FOX NEWS DOES.
WE TACKLE STORIES THE REST OF
THE MEDIA DOESN'T COVER.
>> Kimberly: ONE FOLLOW-UP.
VERY GOOD SO FAR.
HOW ABOUT THE FACT THAT NONE OF
THE TROOPS, NOT SURE THEY ARE
GOING TO BE ARMED.
I DON'T LIKE THAT.
>> Greg: I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S
NECESSARY.
I THINK HE HAS ALREADY PROVED
THE POINT.
HASN'T HE ALREADY, HE'S A
METAPHORICAL WALL.
THE WAY HE RESPONDED WAS ALL
THAT WAS NECESSARY.
SECURITY THEATER.
TRUMP'S ACTIVISTS THEATER.
>> Kimberly: KENNEDY, PERHAPS
THEY'RE GOING TO LINK ARMS AT
THE BORDER.
>> Kimberly: MAY BE.
WHY HAVE PAST PRESIDENTS SENT
THE NATIONAL GUARD IN THE FIRST
PLACE?
MAYBE PRESIDENT BUSH WAS WORRIED
THAT TERRORISTS WERE GOING TO
POUR OVER THE BORDER.
PERHAPS PRESIDENT OBAMA WAS
WORRIED BECAUSE OF THE DRUG WAR
AND THE ESCALATING VIOLENCE AND
HOMICIDES ON THE BORDER.
THIS ISN'T THE FIRST PRESIDENT
WHO HAS DONE THAT.
YOU WOULDN'T KNOW THAT BY THE
HYSTERICAL REACTION ON THE LEFT.
ANYTIME YOU'RE GOING TO SPEND A
BUNCH OF MONEY LIKE THIS, YOU
BETTER HAVE A POINT TO IT
BECAUSE WHEN PRESIDENT BUSH SENT
6,000 NATIONAL GUARD TROOPS, IT
COST ABOUT HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS.
IT'S A LOT OF MONEY AND IT'S
MONEY WE DON'T HAVE.
I ALSO UNDERSTAND IT'S A WAY OF
THE PRESIDENT LOOKING LIKE HE'S
DOING SOMETHING BECAUSE CONGRESS
IS NOT GOING TO GIVE HIM MONEY
FOR THE WALL.
THEY MAY GIVE HIM A LITTLE BIT
OF SEED MONEY.
$1.5 BILLION ISN'T THAT MUCH.
THIS IS THE ONLY OTHER THING HE
CAN DO TO SHOW THAT HE IS DOING
SOMETHING.
WE ALSO HAVE TO ASK, WHAT KIND
OF A HELLHOLE IS HONDURAS?
WHY ARE PEOPLE LEAVING IN DROVES
WHY ARE PEOPLE LEAVING IN DROVE
DROVES?
TAKING A PERILOUS JOURNEY
THROUGH MEXICO.
THE OTHER QUESTION IS WHAT IS
MEXICO'S IMMIGRATION POLICY?
IS THE PRESIDENT PUTTING
PRESSURE ON THEM TO DO THEIR
WORK FOR THAT LEG OF THE JOURNEY
WORK FOR THAT LEG OF THE JOURNE
JOURNEY?
>> Kimberly: CONGRESSMAN.
>> Jason: THE PRESIDENT IS
DOING EXACTLY WHAT HE TOLD
AMERICA HE WOULD DO.
HE NEEDS TO LOCK DOWN THE BORDER
AND GET RID OF THE REWARDS AND
INCENTIVES.
I AM SICK OF TIRED OF THE PEOPLE
IN THE LEFT THING THIS IS YOUR
SHOW AND HE IS JUST PLAYING TO
ITS BASE.
OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS, MORE
THAN 100,000 MINERS HAVE COME
ACROSS THE BORDER.
WHEN YOU ARE AN UNACCOMPANIED
MINOR AND YOU COME ACROSS THE
BORDER, WE DON'T HAVE ANY
VETTING TO FIGURE OUT WHO WE ARE
HANDING YOU TOO.
YOU HAVE 12-YEAR-OLD GIRLS
COMING ACROSS THE BORDER AND WE
ARE HANDING THEM OFF TO WHO
KNOWS WHO.
WHY ISN'T THE LEFT YELLING AND
SCREAMING ABOUT HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND THE SCOURGE OF
DRUGS.
THESE AREN'T ALL PEOPLE COMING
TO JUST MAKE LIFE BETTER FOR
THEIR FAMILIES.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE
PURPOSELY MOVING KIDS INTO
AMERICA.
SOME OF THEM ARE GOING INTO
GANGS.
SOME OF THEM ARE GOING TO
PERVERTS.
YOU DON'T KNOW WHO THEY ARE
GOING TO.
IT'S TIME THE LEFT ACTUALLY
REALIZED WE SHOULDN'T BE
COMPLICIT IN ALLOWING THIS
TRAFFICKING OF CHILDREN.
>> Kimberly: AN IMPORTANT
POINT AND IT SUCH A REAL PROBLEM
POINT AND IT SUCH A REAL PROBLE
PROBLEM.
JUST YESTERDAY THEY MADE THE
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT 99
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS, THEY WERE
IDENTIFIED AS MEMBERS OF MS-13,
THEY WERE TAKEN INTO CUSTODY BY
THE PRESIDENT, HAD THEM ARRESTED
THE PRESIDENT, HAD THEM ARRESTE
ARRESTED.
YOU REALLY HAVE TO BE CAREFUL IN
TERMS OF WHY WOULDN'T YOU?
IT IS NOT MEAN-SPIRITED.
IT IS LOOKING FOR JUSTICE AND
MAKING SURE YOU DO NOT LET
PEOPLE COME IN, UNACCOMPANIED
MINORS, HUMAN TRAFFICKING, GANG
OR CARTEL ELEMENTS COMING IN.
>> Kennedy: WE CAN'T RELY ON
THE GOVERNMENT FOR ALL OF THE
VETTING.
AT ALL THAT WE HAVE PROPER
VETTING PROCESSES IN PLACE
BECAUSE CONGRESS WON'T DO ITS
JOB.
>> Jason: YOU CAN'T CONTINUE
TO HOUSE THEM.
YOU GET TO THE OVERFLOW
SITUATION, THE BAD GUYS KNOW.
THEY HAVE TO RELEASE THEM AND
THEY GO OUT.
>> Juan: I DO THINK THIS IS
THEATER.
ABSOLUTELY THEATER.
LAUNCHED BY PRESIDENT TRUMP IN A
MOMENT WHEN HE IS GOING INTO
CHAOS AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
SENDING OUT TWEETS ABOUT
EVERYTHING, BLAMING EVERYBODY.
BLAMES PRESIDENT OBAMA, BLAMES
THE MEXICAN GOVERNMENT, BLAMES
CALIFORNIA.
IN THIS SITUATION, GREG, I THINK
IT WAS BUZZFEED OR VICE OR
SOMEBODY WHO CALLED ATTENTION TO
IT.
"FOX & FRIENDS" PICKED UP ON IT.
THEN THE PRESIDENT SEES THAT HE
REACTS TO IT.
AND THEN BLOWS IT WAY OUT OF
PROPORTION.
THESE PEOPLE WERE NEVER INTENDED
TO, CROSS THE BORDER EXCEPT TO
POSSIBLY APPLY FOR WHAT IS QUITE
LEGAL, CALLED, GUESS WHAT, YOU
KNOW, THEY WANTED SOME KIND OF
ASYLUM.
>> Kimberly: NOT FOR MS-13
GANG MEMBERS.
>> Juan: THIS IS ALL PART OF
THE VILIFICATION --
>> Kimberly: IT IS NOT
VILIFICATION.
YOU DON'T WANT TO DEAL WITH THE
FACTS.
YOU SAY THAT THE PRESIDENT IS
SQUIRMING.
SQUIRMING AT 51%.
THE HIGHEST --
>> Juan: 39% IN REAL CLEAR
POLITICS AVERAGE.
>> Kimberly: HOW ABOUT
RASMUSSEN?
>> Greg: THEY WERE OFF BY ONE
POINT IN THE ELECTION.
DON'T SPREAD LIES LIKE THAT.
THAT'S A LIE.
>> Juan: RASMUSSEN, IT DOESN'T
REALLY BOW CALL POLLING.
IT DOESN'T GET PEOPLE WHO HAVE
CELL PHONES, DISAPPOINTS ITS
HALF THE.
>> Kennedy: JUAN, LET'S SAY IT
IS THEATER, AND IT MIGHT BE.
THE PRESIDENT, LIKE I SAID,
LOOKING LIKE HE'S DOING
SOMETHING.
BUT THERE IS A PERCEPTUAL EFFECT
IN THAT IMMIGRATION, LEGAL
IMMIGRATION HAS SLOWED DOWN
SINCE THE PRESIDENT TOOK THE
OATH OF OFFICE.
>> Juan: IT'S AT A 46-YEAR LOW
LOW.
>> Kennedy: THERE WAS AN
UPTICK.
WITH DACA UNCERTAINTY.
YOU HAVE FOUR BORDER STATES.
NEW MEXICO, TEXAS, ARIZONA, THEY
HAVE COMMENDED THE PRESIDENT AND
SAID THANK YOU.
WE WELCOME THE HELP.
CALIFORNIA IS VERY MUCH ON THE
FENCE.
DON'T BE SURPRISED IF THERE IS A
MASSIVE RESISTANCE TO DEPLOYING
THE NATIONAL GUARD IN
CALIFORNIA.
DON'T YOU THINK THAT CREATES THE
PERCEPTION THAT CALIFORNIA IS
THE PLACE TO GO BECAUSE THE
BORDER --
>> Kimberly: JUAN, LET ME GET
THIS IN.
>> Kennedy: LIKE IT OR NOT, IT
ALTERS PEOPLE'S BEHAVIOR.
>> Kimberly: AND OTHER CITY IN
CALIFORNIA VOTING TO SUPPORT THE
LAWSUIT AGAINST THE STATE'S
SANCTUARY LAW.
THE PRESIDENT ADDRESSED IT
TODAY.
>> IF YOU LOOK IN CALIFORNIA AND
YOU SEE WHAT'S HAPPENING, IT'S
AN INCREDIBLE PHENOMENON BECAUSE
SANCTUARY CITIES, IT'S THE
WORST.
IT'S BASICALLY A CITY TO PROTECT
A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT ARE BAD
PEOPLE.
REALLY BAD.
>> Kimberly: JUAN, YOUR
RESPONSE.
>> Juan: THE PRESIDENT DIDN'T
GET THE MONEY IN THE BUDGET TO
BUILD A WALL.
PROMISED THE WALL.
ANN COULTER AND PEOPLE ON THE